Donald Trump is once again trying to collude
with a foreign power to win an election.
This time it's 2020 with Ukraine against Joe
Biden.
It sort of sounds like that board game clue.
It's Trump in 2020 with Ukraine against Joe
Biden, and we knew that Trump was willing
to do this because he told us several months
ago when he was interviewed by George Stephanopoulos
on NBA ABC, that if a foreign power came to
him offering help in 2020 he would accept
it.
Sure.
He would look at the info.
He would look at what they had and as shocking
as that was after everything that has happened,
this is actually worse because this is more
than trying to collude, this is, you could
call it bribery, you could call it extortion,
and even those terms don't really cover it
because Donald Trump is withholding $250 million
in aid from Ukraine because they are apparently
unwilling to smear.
Joe Biden and his son Donald Trump directed
Rudy Giuliani to pressure the Ukrainian president
to investigate Joe Biden's son to try to hurt
Joe Biden.
And the new part is what we are now learning
that the White House has actually, uh, been
playing games with this suspending delivery
of 250 million in military aid to Ukraine,
uh, and also refusing an in person White House
visit to the Ukrainian president.
And there's a report now that during a phone
call back in July, Donald Trump asked the
Ukrainian president eight times to investigate
the son of Joe Biden's specifically saying
work with Rudy Giuliani.
In order to do it.
We have video of Rudy, uh, coming up later
in the show on this, asked whether he discussed
Biden in conversation with the Ukrainian president.
Donald Trump said it doesn't matter what I
discussed, which is of course a complete non
denial because the reports are accurate.
And we actually will have video of Trump later
in the show saying that the topic of Biden
did come up during that conversation, although
he didn't, uh, give the specifics.
The word trader is more present and reasonable
in this conversation than it has ever been
before.
The unlimited willingness to just abuse power
in ways that undermine national security and
go against everything that this country is
supposed to stand for and the words bribery
and extortion apply here colloquially, but
this is actually much worse.
Renato Mariotti wrote a really good piece
in politico, a, he's been a guest on the show
that bribery and extortion don't even really
account for what Donald Trump has done here.
Mariachi says that these panels with the lawyers
on TV arguing about is this or isn't criminal
bribery or are the charges bogus?
Mariotti explains that what Donald Trump is
doing here is actually so bad and so immoral
and so unamerican and so beyond what the criminal
code is even equipped to handle that the criminal
statutes we have around bribery and extortion
likely wouldn't even cover what Donald Trump
has done here by withholding aid in exchange
for a smear campaign meant to help him defeat
Joe Biden in 2020 and I don't want you to
misunderstand what I'm saying.
This is bribery.
This is extortion.
This is potentially traders, but this is happening
in a way that is so beyond the scope of what
our justice system can handle, that if Donald
Trump is charged with those crimes, he would
likely not be convicted.
Can Democrats get it together and find a way
to hold Donald Trump accountable and make
something?
Does Ukraine have the call recorded and can
they release it so we can figure out what
was said?
And then there's the additional element here,
which is stunning, which is that this all
may have been a cop too by the White House.
The White House may have even been involved
in leaking this or admitting after the fact
that this took place because of the truth
of the situation may be even worse.
And what I mean by that is the White House
may have calculated that it being known that
$250 million are being withheld because Trump
wants Ukraine to smear Biden.
That may not be as bad as the full scope of
what it is that has actually, uh, transpired
here.
And whether we will ever know the full scope
as usual is a question mark whether there
will be any consequences.
Uh, the trend has been that for this administration,
there are no consequences.
So I'm sticking with, there probably won't
be a, after the break we will have video of
Rudy Giuliani denying and then immediately
admitting that this is something they are
doing.
We will have video of a visibly red and disheveled
Donald Trump, uh, not denying that this is
what is going on.
A lot of stunning video coming up after the
break.
Make sure that you're following the David
Pakman show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
And if you wanna see my first pepper, I've
got a pepper plant, a I harvest it.
Isn't this exciting?
I harvested my first pepper this morning and
posted a video to my Instagram at David dot
pack.
Follow me there.
We'll be right.
We'll be back right after this with extraordinarily
confusing and disturbing video